[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro dans
une lecture native de wolf bonjour jean
patrice carmouze
alors on va recevoir quelqu'un qui est
passionnant c'est etienne klein bonjour
etienne klein bonjour vous alors pour
vous présenter rapidement vous
appartenez à cette grande tradition des
scientifiques philosophes scientifiques
vous n'êtes vous êtes le physicien vous
diriger le laboratoire des sciences de
la matière au cea et vous êtes zotti
docteur en philosophie des sciences et
l'un de vos grands thèmes de recherche
c'est le temps alors vous êtes l'auteur
d'une cinquantaine d'ouvragés dans
lequel le soin vous expliquer la scion
soit vous nous aider à réfléchir sur
elle et puis vous avez également c'est
vous pouvez vous retrouver sur les
internets vous avez un style de
vulgarisation scientifique et puis vous
animé sur france culture le samedi
l'émission la conversation scientifique
vous êtes enfin alpinistes des mets
d'ailleurs on en parlera tout à l'heure
mais d'abord on va s'adresser à votre
essai qui s'appelle le goût du vrai
qu'il est paru dans cette formidable
collection de gallimard qui s'avèrent
les tracts sur des textes courts mais
passionnant et dans ce livre vous
revenez sur quatre tendances qui trahit
tous traduisent ou trahisse notre
rapport à la vérité et à la science et
nathalie on va commencer peut-être par
une de ces tendances eh bien oui on va
commencer par cette première tendance
que vous décrypte etienne klein c'est
que on l'a on accorde davantage
d'importance finalement aux thèses qui
nous plaisent qu'aux autres alors vous
citer nietzsche dans votre ouvrage qui
prophétisait en quelque sorte et bien
que le goût du vrai allait disparaître
faute de plaisir où il faut dire que la
science puisque c'est le fonds doit
dresser qui a été longtemps synonyme de
progrès et plus tôt aujourd'hui porteuse
d'inquiétude alors etienne klein est ce
que ce n'est pas ça qui explique cette
tendance
et puis autre dérive d'ailleurs il en
est des exemples tous les jours
illustration parmi d'autres aux états
unis avec trump notamment c'est ce qu'on
appelle la poste vérité si la vérité
nous est pas très favorable eh bien
qu'il suffit d'en inventer une autre
alors qu'en pensez vous
les vérités le grand jeu quand elles
viennent de la science notamment nous
sommes capables d'inventer toutes sortes
de stratagèmes intellectuelle pour ne
pas croire ce que nous savons vous avez
dit tout à l'heure la science a été
longtemps synonyme de progrès est en
effet rare progresser finalement
configurer le futur d'une façon crédible
et attractive crédible parce que ne
progresse pas c'est pas d'une copie
il faut que ce soit crédible et c'est la
france qui donnent l'idée qu'on se fait
du futur une certaine crédibilité
il faut que cette image aussi du futur
soit attractif sans quoi on ne fait pas
les les efforts voire les sacrifices
qu'on doit accomplir pour que cette idée
qu'on a du futur se réalise concrètement
et aujourd'hui en effet quand les
scientifiques disent ce qu'ils savent
c'est papa des scientifiques qui
travaillent sur les trous noirs ou les
particules élémentaires qui eux
continuent de nous faire rêver
je parle des sentiers qui travaillent
sur l'environnement sur par exemple la
biodiversité le changement climatique la
pollution de l'air de l'eau dans les
airs à ces gens disent des choses savent
qu'ils voient qu'ils constatent étudie
qui sont plutôt attriste et donc on est
pris dans ce piège-là qui est que quand
la science par le futur ce qu'elle dit
est crédible mais pas du doigt attractif
et quand d'autres disent des choses très
attractive
ça n'est pas crédible et donc idée même
de progrès est prise encore tabou et de
ce que m'a fait voir de façon plus nette
que par avant la pandémie en cours que
nous les scientifiques nous n'avons pas
su sait pas très bien pourquoi il ya
sans doute beaucoup de cause mais je
pense qu'on a créé quelque chose
vous parliez de vulgarisation mazuch
tous deux pensent pour y avoir consacré
beaucoup de temps on essaie que et des
choses qu'on n'a pas su faire en mariage
il ya quelque chose qui a joué dans la
démarche peut-être parce qu'on n'a pas
intégré dans la façon de faire de notre
façon de faire ce qu'on appelle lé biais
cognitifs vous en avez cité quelques-uns
y en a d'autres mais moi quand j'étais
plus jeune je pensais que pour faire de
la bonne vulgarisation il faut
travailler une question à fond en
profondeur il ne faut pas qu'on l'a
vraiment travailler alors on devient
capable de clarifier les enjeux et
qu'ils y sont associés
et d y entre les tarifs y est on peut
l'expliquer à toutes sortes de publics
des gens plus ou moins éduqués plus ou
moins scientifiques justement et adapter
son discours au niveau des personnes
auxquels on s'adresse
et je pense que cette démarche
fonctionne que certains cas mais pas
dans tous de sorte que le discours
scientifique est aujourd'hui
complètement noyée confus mélangés à des
opinions des commentaires des si qsi
chacun doit se frayer son propre chemin
dans ce paysage très très très complexe
très très content très contradictoire
avec lui-même cette façon et les
critères qui font qu'on vestiges des
choses les vrais là sont des critères
qui qui relève de sa propre psyché de
son éducation de sa culture de ses
croyances aussi et on n'a plus tous
accès à la même vérité et c'est ça qui
fait que peut-être nous ne faisons plus
autant société qu'auparavant alors c'est
peut-être le moment de s'arrêter sur un
beau jeu que vous utilisez qui est
l'ultra crépy d'ariane isme alors c'est
un néologisme qui est créée d'après
d'après un mot latin c'est quitter ce
support n'est supra crépy d'amou
cordonnier pas au delà de la sandale
c'est dire que ben il faut rester dans
son domaine dans le domaine qu'on
connaît or et vous en était fait l'écho
d'ailleurs dans un précédent traque de
chez gallimard qui s'étaient cette
phrase qu'on va beaucoup entendu pendant
la crise
je ne suis pas médecin mais alors moi
mais moi je pense qu'il faudrait tel ou
tel traitement etc
c'est à dire cet ultra crépy
d'organismes c'est la façon de parler de
ce qu'on ne connaît pas et c'est très
répandu quand même aujourd'hui
oui alors que j'ai remis à la mode ce
mot et on m'a reproché d'avoir un
discours élitiste alors l'ultra crêpier
rien et c'est en effet le fait de parler
au delà des connaissances mais j'ai mis
en avant ce mot non pas pour critiquer
ceux qui sèment à cette tendance
mais pour qu'on en ait conscience
puisque nous sommes dix ans quand vous
discutez à vos amis avec vos amis au
café quand vous discutiez
est ce que c'est possible aujourd'hui
avec 4 cédiez com com
comme tout le monde à l'ultra
capitalisme avis autant de sujets qu'on
maîtrise mal sur la composition de
l'équipe de france de football ou sur
d'autres sujets qu'on maîtrisait tout
aussi mal et et si nécessaire par la
démocratie se dérobe la démocratie ce
n'est pas la république des experts seo
fait que si fait que chacun a le droit
d'exprimer un avis et simplement quand
il s'agit de science ça peut conduire à
des situations fâcheuses et vous citiez
en effet ce krach de mini trail très
court de quelques pages que j'avais
écrit au début d'épidémie j'avais été
frappé de retour du chili je suis arrivé
en france en plein confinement par le
nombre de tweets que je voyais a rédigé
par des plastiques des politiques disait
je ne suis pas venu clamer jeu et
c'était très bizarre qu'on formulation
parce que ces gens reconnaissaient
qu'ils connaissaient rien s'est étonné
que leur part et ensuite il dit qu elles
tendent ordonnance expliquant ce qu'il
fallait faire ou penser à propos de tel
ou tel traitement ou à propos de telle
ou telle mesure décidée quand le
gouvernement
et ça je trouve que c'est quand même une
tendance assez fâcheuse d'ailleurs qui a
été en quelque sorte guéri par la suite
de l'histoire puisque aujourd'hui on ne
voit plus ce genre de fuite avant la
marée compris c'est débile et lisse
d'une affaire sérieuse très complexes et
que vous m'ayez pardon est telle qu'à
veiller quand même et vision vous en
parler de bête début de cet essai ce
sondage absolument surréaliste on
demandait aux gens est ce que vous
pensez qu'il faut utiliser tel
médicament pour soigner le vide et en 10
juillet 56 % des français qui sont
d'accord politisé face
là on est quand même dans un oeuf dans
une sphère absolument incroyable on
n'est pas s'il était d'accord politique
ont de vous le demander si ce médicament
est efficace
oui ces trois styles pensé qu'il était
efficace on leur demandait s'ils étaient
directement s'ils étaient efficaces et
en effet à l'époque où aucune étude tira
petit n'avait eu le temps de conclure et
pour cause il faut une statistique très
loin qu'au pouvoir visiter un médicament
est efficace quand 90% des malades
guérissent concrètement et à ce moment
là ce qui le 5 avril
personne connaissez la réponse à cette
question
ce qui n'a pas empêché 59% des français
de répondre oui 20% de répondre non et
seulement 21 % ce qui réduit est là la
réponse mais 98%
[Rires]
mais en fait c'était un sondage
d'opinion qui renseigne sur ce que
pensent les français ce qu'ils croient
mais qui ne dit rien évidemment de
l'efficacité propre du médicament en
question vous l'évoquiez tout à l'heure
déjà un petit peu
vous parliez de quelque chose que les
scientifiques ont raté la science
contrairement donc à ce qu'on aurait pu
attendre ne semble pas avoir est
ressorti grandi quand même de cette
crise de la deûle à coville est ce qu'il
n'ya pas est ce que ce n'est pas du fait
peut-être même de la faute des
scientifiques des médecins comptent deux
médecins viennent étaler leur désaccord
sur un plateau télé de télévision ça
quand même tendance à altérer l'image de
la science auprès du grand public non
moi j'essaie de ne pas céder à la
tendance de girard viennent de trouver
des boucs émissaires l'air convaincu
qu'on parviendra beaucoup après coup
c'est très facile de dire qu'on a mal
fait
moi j'essaie de tirer des leçons de ce
que j'ai pu constater comme vous en tant
que auditeurs de radio lecteur de
journaux téléspectateurs c'est que la
vie me semble que pendant cette période
on a confondu la science et la recherche
qui tour de chauffe nettement différente
la science c'est encore plus de
connaissances étayé qui constituaient
les bonnes réponses à des questions bien
posée et qu'on a pas lieu de remettre en
cause ce aussi apparaissait une nouvelle
donnée nouvelle observation qui
permettent de remettre en cause qu'on va
considérer comme moi petit maintenant et
par exemple la terre mais par mon nez
n'est pas plate et les rondes l'atome
existe l'univers observable est en
expansion
les espèces vivantes évolué voilà
la scientifique on pourrait même parler
de vérité de science mais ce corpus de
connaissances qui constitue la science
lui même des questions dont nous n'avons
pas les réponses
paris est ce qu'il existe une vie
extraterrestre
est ce que le neutrino une particule
élémentaire assez fascinante est
identique à sa propre antiparticules par
exemple voilà des questions
les chercheurs se fondent ils ne
connaissent pas la réponse et c'est pour
la connaître ou espère connaître qu'il
entame les recherches mettant sur pied
des expériences tt ce type de protocole
et et est donc à rechercher la elle a à
voir avec le doute de façon de
consubstantiel mais on confond la
science et la recherche alors l'idée de
doute qui est consubstantielle à la
recherche bien colonisé la science elle
même et on arrive à ce raccourci qui est
que ton la science c'est le doute
méthylation c'est de l'eau alors moi
avec mon ressenti
mes croyances mes connaissances mais 28
tous mes préjugés
j'ai le droit de dire mon avis sur
n'importe quelle question puisque la
science et le doute et 11 rebonds ont
fait entrer ainsi la science sous la
coupe du sens commun du bon sens et il
me semble que sa salade et forme c'est
la trahison et sa organise cette espèce
de cacophonie qui en dut d'autant plus
facile que comme vous l'avez dit sur les
plateaux télévision d'inviter des gens
qui n'étaient pas d'accord on a eu
l'impression de la science est jugulée
convergent jamais c'est les gens qui
s'engueulent et et alors que on a
empêché des stations les débats puisque
les gens sont violets vous savez les
l'origine étymologique du mot débat le
verbe débattre est un mot du 12e siècle
qui désigne ce qu'il faut faire pour ne
pas se battre
elle n'a pas dû monter celle éventuelle
entre le pape et ses pratiques et
politesse de l'esprit c'est il respecter
l'avis de l'autre et de discuter
bref tout le contraire de ce qu'on
appelle un débat sur sa peine chaîne
d'information continue là il reste très
peu de temps j'aimerais qu'on dise un
mot peut-être de psychisme sensible pour
prendre encore de la hauteur faire cette
ascension conclusive
etienne klein donc on va parler de votre
livre paru cette année également
psychisme attend ascensionnel paru chez
arthaud alors c'est un livre
d'entretiens d'entretien où il est
question de mental une passion que vous
entretenez depuis vous avez l'âge de 20
ans alors vous écrivez que l'alpinisme
est une affaire de transmission et
qu'elle induit aussi un sentiment de
présence à soi et au milieu alentours
alors quelle expérience de l'espace et
du temps la montagne induit-elle pour le
physicien le philosophe et l'alpiniste
que vous êtes d'abord on a parlé du film
en couleur la montagne ce genre de
confinement est quand même dans des
situations
je parle du passage difficile où les
genres de centration un outil votre
espace temps les gros centres et parce
qu'il ya des gestes très précis à
conduire et on est en quelque sorte dans
une note dans une petite bulle
d'espace-temps antonin artaud cela
plusieurs reprises dans le vagin disait
quand ton grave
l'esprit devient mince comme une main
est la main devient le lieu dans lequel
tout le corps se concentrent canton au
contraire on est dans des passages
beaucoup plus facile même quand on est
dans la descente sur des chemins de
randonnée alors là la concentration dans
l'espace temps qu'on a connu dans les
passages difficiles aboutir au drame
dilatation soldats irakiens d'esprit on
s'ouvre est une sorte de dépoussiérage
de l'esprit qui est tout à fait
incroyable comme si l'esprit finalement
c'était surtout de gaz eau comprime dans
les passages difficiles et puis 10 expan
quand on lui laisse
la possibilité de se relaxer de se
détendre et moi j'ai jamais fait de
course en montagne
kim est ramenée à mon point de départ
dans l'état où j'étais un moment de de
partir s'il ya quand même de
transmutation des produits tant que
cette sorte d'itinérance qui est à la
fois libre parce qu'on est libre
montagne n'a pas d'ordre n'est pas
soumis à des contraintes à part celle de
la montagne elle même
on est libre et en même temps on est on
est responsable cela crée une sensation
très spéciale qui fait que en effet
j'aime
j'y allais et je manque de ne pas y
aller quand c'est un petit pas une épine
et ben voilà on va essayer de renverser
de graff est très vite
merci infiniment etienne que je rappelle
donc psychisme ascensionnel c'est chez
arthaud et puis le goût du vrai ccc dans
la mer les tracts de gallimard merci
infiniment et emelin merci toujours au
revoir
[Musique]